Speaker 1: I want to play a clip for you today
from C-SPAN.
Now, C-SPAN is not a place where you necessarily
expect the most sort of unhinged political
discussions.
C-SPAN generally does a good job of moderating
relatively sober and respectful discussion.
Even when kind of kooky people call in, they
tend to do a pretty good job with it.
Well, during the show Washington Journal on
C-SPAN recently, there was a caller from Tennessee
and that caller called in upset that there
were minorities on his TV screen giving opinions.
And he said he doesn't like it.
He wants to go back to the way things kind
of used to be.
And for those who are only listening to this
clip, there's an Asian guy and a black woman
who are on the panel on Washington Journal.
And the guy is Nicholas Wu from Politico.
The woman is Ebony McMorris from the American
Urban Radio Network.
And take a look at this and then we'll discuss
it.
This is really something.
Speaker 2: Comment for them, please.
Speaker 3: When I was a little boy, listen,
I'm 83 years old when I was a little boy.
Speaker 1: But I think that, by the way, I
think the caller is a man, although although
maybe not, I don't know.
Speaker 2: Okay.
We're going to stop it there.
Let's go to Nancy.
Apologize for that.
Speaker 1: I'm sorry.
And I didn't even started at the beginning.
Let's go to the beginning.
I apologize.
Speaker 3: Current things here in America
that's going on, particularly in the press
and the politics of America.
I want to know if we could cut out some of
this, if we could cut out some of these these
liberal things that are going on in America,
just like on the TV now we have two minorities
and I'm not sure minorities.
I'm 83 years.
Speaker 2: Taller.
This that's that shouldn't be a factor.
And the guests that we invite to our program,
which we did invite.
So what's your question or comment for them,
please?
Speaker 3: I was a little bored.
Listen, I'm 83 years old.
I was a little boy.
The colored people here.
Speaker 2: Okay, we're going to stop it there.
Let's go to Nancy.
Apologize for that.
Now.
Speaker 1: The colored people are bothering
this 83 year old man or woman.
Now, I know many people will react to this
by saying this is an 83 year old.
These are not common views.
Well, the issue here is that these are actually
relatively these are more common views than
we would like to admit.
But a lot of younger people realize you can't
say that out loud.
You're not supposed to out loud say, I'm really
bothered by all these non white people I'm
seeing in movies and on television and they
even sometimes just call it woke.
I mean, woke for some people has become a
paraphrase in a sense, for I'm seeing a lot
of liberals with different identities participating
and being allowed to give opinions.
And I don't like that now.
Ebony McMorris, who was the black woman on
the panel, she tweeted after the fact, quote,
I was trying to hold it in, but I promise
you, I felt all my ancestors rushed through
my body.
Nicholas Wu was right.
Pedro was a master at intercepting that.
Next time the response may be different.
And this is really you know, the person says,
I don't I don't have a problem with minorities
or what they're kind of saying is I'm not
a racist.
I just don't want minorities on my TV screen
giving me political opinions.
I don't want to many minorities in my government
or in my neighborhood or in the same waiting
rooms as me type of moment.
And what really makes me kind of sad, it bums
me out the looks on the faces of the guests.
There's a bit of I've dealt with this before
sort of look and that is that that's that's
sad.
It really is.
And so when we talk about well, when they
say that they're conservative.
What do they want to conserve or what is what
do they want to go back to?
Because for many of them, they believe we've
already gone too far.
They want conserving means.
Actually, let's go back.
We often say vaguely, well, they want to go
back to sort of the fifties, right, where,
yes, there were minorities around, but they
were much more it was much more okay to openly
say these are second tier people.
They're not like us.
Yes, women were around, but they were much
more stringently subservient to men.
They're talking about the fifties.
And if this is an 83 year old caller, 1955,
they would have been about six years old.
That is exactly what they are kind of thinking
back to.
And this is different.
This is what is also fascinating is because
of the Trump era, we're really used to the
neo reactionary, cartoonish conservative JFK
Jr, still alive and QAnon and this type of
stuff.
This is much more the 1950s conservative that
we would see a lot more like in the Bush era,
when they would talk about the Moral Majority
and getting back to God and Christianity and
all these different things.
That's this caller this is not really it doesn't
sound to me a Trump histrionic, neo reactionary.
It's more of of that and it's quite sad.
And it's still around 83 years old, but it's
still around.
Send me your thoughts.
You can find me on Twitter at David Pakman.
We'll take a quick break and be right back.
The David Pakman Show does depend on our audience
to support the work that we do.
We are audience funded viewers, listeners
to the podcast, people watching on free speech
TV or checking out a YouTube clip here or
there.
We have a membership program you can sign
up at join Packman dot com.
We do an extra show every day for our members
called the Bonus Show.
And Alex Jones really doesn't like the bonus
show.
Speaker 2: Oh, the bonus show where you want
to make money and everybody else that makes
money to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
I love the bonus show.
Alex Jones hates it.
Take that however you will.
You can sign up at join Packman dot com.
You'll also get a commercial free audio and
video stream of the show every single day,
up to 6 hours before everybody else gets it.
It's some pretty big time stuff, and I would
love for you to sign up.